to our labor and work-life forum I hope
you did not wear your Nike shoes maybe
you did or did not buy a Barbie doll
recently and you were careful in what
you in what you were drinking last night
at as you were having your dinner I wore
canadian-made jacket which I assumed was
made by good labor and american-made
shoes but I didn't quite check my
t-shirt and my underwear so I don't know
but today we're gonna have a Naomi Klein
who's the author of this book no logo
which is about the corporate global
branding and all the various things we
can or cannot do with the things that
are being done to make sure that if
we're buying Nike they really are good
guys rather than all bad guys
I assume alfred knopf and company is a
good guy so we bring bringing out this
book she's also just recently had a
piece of that in the New York Times
expressing sympathy with a bunch of anti
WTO protests in Seattle which will be
counter to everything you've heard from
all the economists in the group and
therefore it's probably will please you
know end the only floor is yours the
podium is yours
thank you very much like to thank Alain
Bernard and Jack Trumper and Jef
Ballinger who are all responsible for
for inviting me here today it's a great
honor um a couple of months ago I I got
an email from someone who I just met and
he said you know when you told me that
you had just written a book about
anti-corporate activism I was only
pretending to know what on earth you
were talking about then I went home and
I turned on the television set and saw
what was going on in Seattle and I
realized what you were talking about at
the time critics accused the anti WTO
protesters in Seattle of ignorance of
coming together in a jumble of unrelated
slogans that degenerated into petty
vandalism what I want to argue today is
that that's not true at all that there
was a common cause in Seattle and that
was that the multinational corporation
has been identified as the root cause of
the degradation of labor standards human
rights and environmental standards even
when the protest degenerated into
rioting the targets of their rage were
still coherent if crudely expressed
McDonald's the gap
Levi's Starbucks I believe that behind
the protests outside of Nike town behind
the pie and Bill Gates his face behind
the bottle shattering at those
McDonald's windows in Seattle and even
behind the attacks on those ecommerce
sites on the Internet there is something
too visceral for most conventional
measured measures to track a kind of bad
rude rising against the global brands
the windows that shattered in Seattle
weren't just any windows they were
symbolic windows windows opening on to
the new economy that was what was under
attack and behind the shattering glass
we are also seeing the beginnings of a
new agenda the need for enforceable
regulations governing labor
environmental and human rights standards
in the global economy the need to the
need to rein in corporate power on the
global level so that corporations are
ruled by citizens rather than the other
way around
the questions I want to answer today is
why now because of course labor
environmental and human rights violation
are not new why then are they drawing
people to the streets in the thousands
all of a sudden the answer has to do
with an ideology that has gripped the
corporate world over the past 15 years
and has sent it into euphoric
convulsions in the age of e-commerce
that is the idea that in order to be a
successful multinational corporations
you need to produce brands not products
the idea is that anyone can produce a
product in the global economy and look
at what happened to IBM when it almost
went under in the late 80s competing
based on value is a loser's game they
say the market was flooded with
identical pcs and IBM did not have a
strong enough brand to compete of course
we know today that IBM has reincarnated
itself into being about solutions no
longer about these clunky machines it is
about the global economy itself in this
context of hostility towards products
the brand has evolved from a mark of
quality on a product to a badge of
courage for the consumer Nike is the
most popular tattoo in North America the
Nike swoosh that is in this corporate
formula the brand has little to do with
the product rather it is a free-standing
idea the goal of the successful brand
has become nothing short of
transcendence from the world of things
so we've had these series of corporate
epiphanies in the past 15 years
Nike we are told is no longer a shoe
company it is a sports company it is
about the idea of transcendence through
sports Starbucks we are told is not a
coffee company it is a community company
Diesel is about creating a movement
Microsoft is not about software it is
about communication the product becomes
a medium to express the brand's idea and
it is one medium among many like a
billboard and as we know as these
companies have transcended they have in
many way in many cases stopped producing
their own products entirely and there's
been an interesting parallel with other
the rise of celebrity super brands as
corporations like Nike and Starbucks
have occupied the role of celebrities in
our culture the celebrities in our
culture are increasingly envisioning
themselves as corporations as brands so
we have the Martha Stewart's the Michael
Jordan's the Jerry Seinfeld's but what's
really interesting is that increasingly
just as Nike has stopped producing its
own sneakers many of these super branded
humans have also begun to separate
themselves from anything that could
broadly be described as doing things we
have Michael Jordan who has transcended
the need to play basketball just as Nike
as Nike has transcended the need to make
running shoes and he has become a pure
brand he is about the Jordan attitude
and in fact has become the first
celebrity endorser to have his own
celebrity endorsers we have Wayne
Gretzky very similar stalked playing
hockey so that he can be a full time
brand Jerry Seinfeld gave up the sitcom
why bother
and what's really interesting is of
course we know that the true celebrities
of our branded era are not the
basketball stars or the running shoes
but the CEOs themselves and I was very
interested to learn that that that Bill
Gates had stepped down as CEO of
Microsoft he too has transcended to
become pure brand he is pure bill of
course the the the end result of this
type of branding economy is seen not in
the corporeal world of things but online
in the IP OS the netscape's and Amazon
comms the ultimate transcendence is of
course occurring on the Internet these
companies exist as ideas of themselves
free from products entirely it's
tempting to dismiss branding mania as a
flavor of the week just a little bit
more management babble what I'm arguing
here is that this seemingly innocuous
idea has had two major effects on our
culture transformative effects which
taken together explain the rise of
anti-corporate activism that we saw in
Seattle and these two effects I'll
separate into two categories no space
and no jobs
the brand needs to express its idea how
does it do that it needs to project
itself onto as many surfaces as possible
that is how a company that is about an
idea not a product becomes real through
sponsorship of cultural events by
launching its own lifestyle magazine in
the case of Starbucks or a line of
furniture in the case of Ernest
Hemingway by building palatial super
stores in the case of everyone through
new and exciting brand extensions if you
think of the brand as a balloon with
nothing much at the center because of
course the product has magically
disappeared this process of absorbing
cultural space is how it staves off its
own deflation everything is a tableau
for the brand and the brand needs to
write on these surfaces in order to
exist advertising agencies have started
to think of themselves not as marketers
but as brand factories in fact there is
an advertising firm in my hometown of
Toronto that is called the brand
factories and in fact this is the true
production of our information economy
we've seen the rise of the cool hunting
industry which didn't exist before 1993
and is now a ballooning industry the
role of this of this industry is to comb
our culture comb the back alleys our
schools our playing fields and find
content for the brands to make them real
find precious ideas heroes political
movements and sell them back to the
brands I want to stress that this
process is not about advertising
it is about production the goal is no
longer Association but merger with the
culture advertising used to be about
associating a product with a particular
lifestyle with the with a particular
aspirational quality such as beauty what
we're seeing now are 3d ads that are so
all-encompassing they cease to be
advertisements at all and become our
culture Nike for instance once it
decided that it was about sports was
Nolan was not satisfied with simply
attaching its name to sporting events it
has started buying sporting events
outright
Roots a Canadian company which has the
brand meeting of summer camp the
Canadian wilderness has built a summer
camp a branded summer camp which you can
visit for any length of time and where
you are completely cocooned in the roots
brand everything is owned by roots
Mentos used to try to associate itself
with with rock music it now owns the
Mentos freshmaker tour swatch whose
whose brand is time not watches has
launched its own time
it's called internet time and it's
branded time and it divides the day into
swatch beats Benetton of course has
become a campaigner for death row
inmates it is about a political movement
the goal of branding is seamless
integration with their brand idea
becoming real-world incarnations of
their myths the brand is the cultural
infrastructure the culture is brand
content now of course within this new
culture a kind of global claustrophobia
sets in for many people cool hunting of
course is a form of legalized mass
stalking students are enlisted as self
marketers more and more they are given
disposable cameras and and journals to
keep track of their of their friends
haircuts and so on and and the latest
lingo to sell it to the brand masters
what this means is that there's no
gestation period for new scenes for new
ideas and I think as a young person
you're faced with a couple of choices
one is that you can turn yourself into a
commodity become what Tom Peters calls a
brand called you a professional consumer
to sell that information at a premium to
your corporate clients or you can do
something else you can begin to run in
the other direction I said that branding
is about transcending products but what
does that really mean it means that
products more specifically the people
who produce those products have just
gotten a very major demotion in the
economic hierarchy because in this
equation products are banal whereas
branding is what is exciting but
branding is an enormous ly expensive
Enterprise getting
more expensive every day the money needs
to be saved somewhere to fuel these
ambitious corporate utopias
the Nike towns the roots lodges the
swatch times where it's being saved is
in the act of production companies that
used to be satisfied with a hundred
percent markup from what it cost to
produce their product to what they would
sell it at retail are now not settling
for four nothing less than four hundred
percent the idea is that you can let
someone else produce your product and
you will buy the products source them
like a raw commodity better yet get lots
of other people to produce your products
and have them compete against each other
over who can give you the best price
after all what you produce is not the
product but the image the brand this is
the Nike paradigm don't own a single
factory and let a web of contractors and
subcontractors around the world fall
over each other to offer to make your
shoes at the cheapest price the reason
why Nike is so significant is because
they have spawned armies of copycats
levi-strauss
laid off 13,000 workers in the past
three years but when they laid off those
workers it was reported in the news as
if once again some American factories
closed they moved to Mexico they moved
to China but of course that's not what
happened at all those factories that
were closed in El Paso Texas were never
reopen they turned into something else
in the branding economy they turned into
contracts to be placed with contractors
Levi's would never own those factories
again they would be produced for the
most part in free trade zones two
hundred and fifty billion dollars worth
of trade flows through these zones often
called maquiladoras or export processing
zones every day now I don't think I need
to tell anybody in this room what a free
trade zone is we've all heard the horror
stories from Mexico Indonesia Honduras
and China the 12 and 16-hour days the
forced overtime the cramped dorm rooms
and the poverty wages what I'm arguing
however is that these horrid conditions
that have become the cliches of our
global economy are a byproduct of the
branding equation
and we might clean it up a little bit
but the basic structure remains the same
work is being degraded by the obsession
with marketing and increasingly those
concerned with labor cannot afford to
ignore the mechanics of branding because
they are interrelated levi-strauss can
write a wonderful code of conduct and it
can even enforce that code of conduct
with some of its with some of its
contractors but what it shut down those
factories it made a decision to make
production a less central part of its
corporation and therefore a more
marginal play a more marginal role in
the economy production work is being
marginalized in this way throughout the
economy and that is why these abuses are
occurring in a systemic way a similar
degradation of work is of course
occurring not just in the factories but
at the North American and European mall
occurring at the service sector end of
the equation for many of the same
companies the gap linkie Starbucks
McDonald's the so-called mik work sector
has pioneered a new kind of labor the
idea is that this is work that doesn't
really matter
disposable temporary work which is
interesting because when I interviewed
factory managers in the Philippines and
in Indonesia they often told me that the
women who were making the shoes and the
sweaters were just kids they were just
earning a little bit of money to send
home to their families the same idea the
same rhetoric I don't think that you can
compare the conditions working at the
mall to working in the export processing
zone in fact it's obscene to do so but
from from the perspective of the
corporate employer there is an
undeniable symmetry at work because at
no point during the economic equation
whether it's at the production end or
the service end does a company like the
gap or Walmart ever have to confront the
reality that workers with families are
supporting themselves on their jobs on
the wages they pay the two largest
employers in America as you own all know
our Walmart which defines full time as
28 hours a week and manpower Inc the
largest temp service agency in the world
Microsoft you know what's interesting
when you talk about Mik jobs and
sweatshops
people always say well what about
silicon
what about silicon gold isn't that where
the good jobs are and of course
Microsoft has been has been the one to
perpetuate in many ways the myth of
silicon silicon gold and in fact there
was a time when it was true but today
Microsoft keeps between 4,000 and 6,000
of its workers more than a third of its
entire workforce classified as temps at
Microsoft they call themselves perma
temps because many of them have been
working at the company for years and
they work side by side with employees
who are performing the exact same tasks
as them but of course they have stock
options and security in security and
benefits Microsoft has outsourced so
many of its departments to temp agencies
outsource them in their entirety that
they had to hire a temp agency to manage
all of their temp agencies they said you
know we can't do it that's not one of
our core competencies so we're seeing a
class system emerge a class system not
just between first and third world not
just a class system in the growing
disparity within countries but even a
class system within individual companies
like Microsoft and I think that there is
an interesting relationship with the
branding economy that I spoke of earlier
in terms of marketing because everywhere
the same brands that have aggressively
sought to weave their way into our
culture in these quasi spiritual ways
are attempting to opt out in these very
concrete ways through as full-time study
employers so you have these companies
the Nikes the Starbucks the McDonald's
that are at once
culturally omnipresent and economically
disengaged like phantoms floating over
the economy the effect of this is that
brands are courting backlash there is
nothing in their new deal with workers
as employers of Tempe's part-timers and
contractors that is going to protect
them from the kind of public rage that
we saw in Seattle well I had the
opportunity to visit a Nike factory when
I was in the Philippines at closing time
and I watched the workers line up at the
gate and opened their bags for bag check
they were being searched by by military
guards and as I was watching this I saw
I
I thought about what it was like to go
to a North American mall at closing time
and to watch all of the the so-called
myth workers at the gap and Benetton
open up their bags for their managers
for bag check it's a ritual at the mall
it happens every day and once again you
know the this is not the same situation
the workers at the mall are not being
searched by guards with submachine guns
but the assumption is the same the
assumption is that given half a chance
of course these workers would rob their
employer blind which brings us back to
Seattle and that's shattering glass I
think that when the mechanics of no
space and the reality of no jobs are
taken together you get what I call no
logo the rise of anti-corporate activism
and as I mentioned I think we saw we're
seeing a little bit with these attacks
on the e-commerce sites the largest
ecommerce sites on the net a couple of
years ago the internet was still
approximating a public Commons but there
has been a virtual coup d'etat in in
just about two years and I think that
it's that coup d'etat this virtual coup
d'etat that has provoked these attacks I
think we're also seeing the seeds of
this rage in the campaign that targeted
McDonald's in England the so-called
McLibel trial the longest the longest
civil trial in British history where two
British environmentalists who were sued
for libel turn the tables on McDonald's
and put and put the corporation on trial
for basically crimes against humanity I
think we've seen it in the way Nike and
the gap and Disney and Kathie Lee
Gifford have all become symbols for
sweatshop labor and to varying degrees
that labor activists have made a
concerted decision to target the most
visible the most polished brands on the
brand scape and use the power of
branding against itself I think we've
seen some of these tactics in the
campaign against shale oil on the Niger
Delta it was because Ken Sahrawis WA and
his colleagues were willing to name
Shell as the force behind the Nigerian
dictatorship and their oppression that
that campaign drew international
attention I think we're also seeing it
in the campaign against genetically
modified an engineer
foods with the targeting of Monsanto and
and the targeting of Brandt particularly
of brand-name food companies because
even though Monsanto is isn't itself a
brand although I should say that
Monsanto is about to launch a line of
branded foods when campaigners couldn't
couldn't get the attention of Monsanto
what they did what they started to do is
target brand name soup supermarket brand
names like Nestle and Cadbury and
because of that they got changed from
Monsanto and Monsanto agreed not to
launch its controversial Terminator
technology which would have made jeans
which would have made seeds infertile
after one year people often make the
mistake of viewing these campaigns as
mere consumer boycotts which are simply
promoting ethical consumption basically
glorified shopping guides by don't buy
Nike by New Balance and so on what I'm
arguing is that that's not that these
are not consumer campaigns these are
political campaigns that are using
corporations as political tools to
achieve political gains all over the
world citizens are fighting these macro
battles against sweatshops against
genetic engineering against human rights
abuses against monopolies in the in
protect Infotech industries and they're
doing it by focusing in on one or two
large brand-name corporations because
it's a very effective tactic the best
tool of these campaigns funnily enough
is the logic of branding itself we have
become a culture of facades and
activists are creating deliberately
creating sharks sharp juxtapositions
between production and brand image one
thinks of the Indonesian Nike worker
sponsored by American unions going to
Nike town with cameras in tow and
capturing that moment when she sees that
the shoes that she produced for $2 a day
are selling for a hundred and twenty
dollars at Nike town when thinks of the
the efforts of the National Labor
Committee to to use Kathy Lee Gifford's
image as the TV mom and juxtapose that
with the reality of child labor
I'm thinking of a Rage Against the
Machine video that's airing on MTV at
the moment which begins with with the
lineup of of figures hunched over sewing
machines and then cuts to the slogan
everybody in denial playing of course on
everybody in khakis theme more and more
what activists are doing is pelting the
brand facade with the reality of
production the effectiveness of these
tactics has to do with the arrogance of
branding itself the seeds of discontent
are part of its very DNA because once a
company decides that it's too true
product is its image not its product it
becomes enormous leave ulnar abode to
these semiotic terror tactics a
corporate brand balloon after all is by
its very nature filled with hot air I
think Seattle itself was a kind of giant
culture jam if we think about the images
that Seattle left us with police dressed
up in riot gear protecting Nike town or
a Starbucks outlet French farmers
handing out Roquefort cheese outside of
a McDonald's labor activists hanging a
500-foot anti-sweatshop banner on the
side of an old navy store a topless
protester pictured in newsweek was
better than nike better naked than nike
scrawled on her back but this is about
much more than playing games with
imagery the rallying cry of the student
anti-sweatshop movement has become
disclosure the seemingly innocuous
demand that brand name companies like
champion JanSport and Nike provide
universities with a list of all the
contract factories that produce their
goods when several companies complied
with this On January 1st it was a major
victory not only because having these
names will increase communication
between students and workers but also
because it chips away at the distance
these companies have so successfully
placed between their brand image and
their sites of production it pulls the
brand balloons a little closer to the to
the ground I have found that there is a
clear connection between the branding
ambition of these companies
and the companies that are being
targeted by these campaigns in a sense
the more inflated the brand balloon the
more likely it is to have bread armies
of pin wielding critics anxious to watch
the brand balloon fall to the ground
Phil Knight well before Nike had become
a symbol for sweatshop labor as Phil
Knight has admitted himself said somehow
the emotions we create imply they're
opposites and I think that was a
prescient remark because as a culture we
have a very deeply ambivalent
relationship with the brands that have
so aggressively enveloped our public
spaces and so it is the brands that are
most in twined with our culture that are
getting hit the hardest
it's the Nikes it's the Starbucks it's
the Microsoft's the gaps and even on
university campuses one's own school
insignia some of the most successful
anti corporate campaigns have begun with
a brand's aggressive sponsorship or
partnership in a school system the best
example of this is Pepsi a company which
is in many ways pioneered the branding
of Education with a wave of exclusive
vending deals in Inked in their early
90s with high schools and university
campuses they would they would be the
sole distributor of soft drinks on
campus they would also get to pass out
Pepsi Achievement Awards in high schools
and get ads in the halls the idea was
that they would beat out coke and the
brand wars by getting at the target
market Generation Next as they call it
when they don't have a choice but
because Pepsi was the first corporation
in many ways to really truly break the
brand barrier to get into the schools it
also sparked its own backlash in 1993
students said some Canadian universities
were upset about the fact that their
school had signed one of these exclusive
deals so they started doing some
research they didn't know what they
would find but what they found was that
there was a little known boycott that
had been called against Pepsi and it had
to do with the fact that Pepsi was doing
business with Burma they that they
started all they started out being
interested in this issue because they
were concerned about corporatization
they were concerned
about being over marketed to and over
branded and it led them to this human
rights concern
pretty soon god a boycott stickers were
finding their way onto textbooks and
onto lockers
it was a case of reverse branding Pepsi
had tried to brand these students and
now these students were turning Pepsi
into their poster child for the free
Burma movement the campaign spread to
schools in Britain and to the US and the
decisive moment in the campaign happened
right here in April 1996 Harvard
rejected a million dollar vending deal
with Pepsi and they cited as their
reason the company's holdings in Burma
the issue made the New York Times and
then it was raised at a shareholder
meeting and pretty soon Pepsi pulled out
of Burma it had a domino effect sparking
dozens of other companies to withdraw
including Levi's Liz Claiborne Heineken
and the list goes on the Pepsi campaign
had the thrill of the brand boomerang
it's the same thrill I think that
students experience when they target
Nike for sweatshop abuses after their
entire athletics program has been
branded by the swoosh no company has
branded this generation like Nike has
and I think that given the opportunity
to brand Nike back it's just too good to
resist and I think it's interesting that
students have not always played such an
enlightened role in these in these types
of issues during the infamous 1912
sweatshops strike at Lawrence mill not
far from here Harvard students received
class credit if they agreed to serve in
the militia against the striking textile
workers and many of them did that was
1912 now students are leading the fight
against sweatshops and corporate logos
are providing the infrastructure for
their global movement where a previous
generation was entreated to follow the
money this generation of activists is
following the logo from their college
sweatshirt to the sweatshops of Honduras
from the swooshes on their school
gymnasium floor to the factories of
Indonesia from their Starbucks lattes to
the Sun scorched fields of Guatemala
being a target market for every powerful
brand on the planet means having a
direct personal connection
to ever to other young people who make
the clothes who pick the coffee who grow
the genetically modified corn all around
the world there are many other levers
besides the University being used to
extract corporate responsibility from
brands their shareholder pressure for
one there's also municipal and state
governments who are deciding not to
enter into large contracts with
companies who use sweatshop labor or
sorry or who are doing business with
repressive regimes like Burma here in
Cambridge the City Council has a so
called selective purchasing agreement
which states that it will not enter into
contracts with any company invested in
Burma and at the state level as you all
know there's the controversial
Massachusetts Burma law which has upped
the stakes in this grassroots selective
purchasing movement to such a degree
that the international business
community has has rallied to defeat the
law both in the US courts and at the
World Trade Organization
I talked briefly about about how
activists are dealing with applying
pressure to companies that are in fact
not brand based we talked about Monsanto
there's many other examples of this
every even raw resources turn into
brands eventually and there was just a
recent victory when Home Depot agreed
that they would not carry old growth
would after the year 2002 this is after
many years of pressuring logging
companies which of course have no brand
image to worry about the brand and their
logging companies were entirely
unconcerned it wasn't until they
targeted their brand name their brand
name consumers the Home Depot's that
they finally got their attention of
course this issue is far from resolved
it's easy to be seduced by these success
stories to believe as Harvard professor
Deborah Spahr has suggested that through
this activist spotlight phenomenon
corporations are are becoming
voluntarily shamed into responsible
corporate citizenship that ethics has
become the third bottom line
it would be wonderful if that was the
case but the truth is that these
victories are haphazard and piecemeal
the real success stories are has been
the success of organizing and education
organizers and educators many of whom
are in this room have put these global
and justices onto the political agenda
but that does not mean that real change
has taken place in fact the pace of
change to quote Jeff Ballinger has been
glacial that is why Seattle was so
significant it was the next step making
creating a bridge from these single
issue corporate campaigns to a broader
more structural critique of the
regulatory bodies that are playing
referee in this race to the bottom it's
also why the student rejection of
corporate controlled codes of conduct on
a sweatshop issue is so very significant
because it means that students are not
falling for the easy PR solutions
offered by multinationals and are
instead returning to basic principles of
self-determination I'm heartened by the
student driven workers rights consortium
as an alternative model to the White
House's Fair Labor Association first of
all of course it means that students are
going to be in direct communication with
workers which is crucial but I think
it's also encouraging because what these
campaigns are really about is not a
battle over which brand is more ethical
it's a classic power struggle it's a
struggle over who is going to write the
rules for our global economy will it be
citizens workers and their democratic
institutions or will it be corporations
and their trade organizations we're lit
will labor rights in fact be branded
which when students organize themselves
to write meaningful codes of conduct for
their schools business partners they're
doing more than making sure that their
sweatshirts and baseball hats are made
under ethical conditions they're
practicing writing democratic rules for
the global economy laying the
intellectual framework for a global New
Deal students in other words are
teaching themselves how to regulate
global corporations if there is a more
crucial
gaile one can get out of post-secondary
education I'd certainly like to hear
about it thank you very much for
listening
so I'm just gonna take questions for the
next little while you've made a
distinction between boycotts and
political movements and suggested this
was more about political movements and
yet most of the examples I've heard you
citing were about actions well I think
all of them against companies and I just
wondered what you thought would be a
more effective tool in this fight would
be to continue the battle against
companies would you say is moving at a
glacial pace or actually move against
governments and some people say that
governments have no power in this era of
globalization others would argue against
that um that's one question can I sneak
in another or I stopped the whole idea
of branding is culture I'm wondering
what that means or if you thought about
what it means to institutions that have
long existed simply because of culture
that are our cultural institutions what
kind of effect does this have on those
yeah yeah
I'll take the the first one first I do I
I certainly have do go into that at
great length in the book and there's
obviously a corresponding relationship
with the the rise of these sort of
pseudo public branded spaces like the
Nike towns and and you know it's what's
interesting about the the super stores
in particular is that they all use the
language of the public sphere like that
they're the town square it's the third
meeting place and so on
and so that this is a process of
replacing the public sphere and I think
you see that you know in a truly
Orwellian form in case like celebration
Florida owned by Disney a fully
privatized town and of course the this
the growth of the corporate sponsorship
industry which has grown by 700 percent
since 1985 in the US has corresponded to
a decline the public sector so it so it
is there it is a true competition and
it's a competition on a sort of macro
political level where you see the
starving out of the public sector by
corporations paying less for
tax but then it's also a war sort of a
power struggle on the micro level of an
individual arts of it where say it
starts off with a logo in the corner and
suddenly the entire event has been
privatized and artists are sort of
playing an opening act for the logo
which is the true star and I have lots
of examples of that in the book the
issue of whether of whether this is
going after corporations is effective or
whether it's more effective to go after
governments what I was trying to what
I'm talking about with Seattle is that I
believe that Seattle does mark a shift
in the US and I think that shift has
been happening in other countries before
Seattle with protests outside of AIPAC
outside of g7 g8 summits and and that
and that we that activists are more and
more going after the global regulatory
bodies and pressuring their own
governments and and that that is so that
they're not entirely abandoning
governments the Selective purchasing is
a government response its municipal and
state governments responding where the
federal government's have stepped aside
and said that they don't want to attach
any sorts of regulations to trade but
but more importantly I think that the
reason why these corporate campaigns are
interesting to look at is because they
are opening the door to the global
economy that essentially everything
about this discussion is structured to
make individuals feel that they need a
degree in international law to even
participate in the discussion that is
enormous ly alienating everybody feels
that they were sick the day everybody
else learned what the OECD stood for and
that that what I'm finding particularly
for young people is that you know
they're learning about Nike and they're
learning but Nike has a metaphor for the
global economy gone awry they can get
their head around you know Michael
Jordan makes twenty million dollars
Indonesian workforce could have their
lives changed with that much money and
and through this sort of popular
education project of using the brands as
popular education tools we are finding
our way into this very arcane exclusive
Maryna and of course we're not wanted
there at all as the pepper spray and
tear gas shows
in your book you discuss how a number of
the part-time US employees it has
tripled since 1968 and the hamburger
flipping service sector led by
McDonald's is responsible for evening
significant portion of this growth and
part-time work you mentioned how
McDonald's been embroidered in bribery
scandals during the Union drives in
Germany and how the French government
arrested ten McDonald managers for
violating labor laws and trade union
rights what are the possibilities for
organizing fast-food workers and other
workers from part-time sectors well you
know in many ways this is how I kind of
got interested in this issue I've been
covering I've covered Union drives as a
journalist in at Walmart McDonald's
Starbucks borders and there have been
these there's no doubt that there are
that there are these pockets of of
resistance in the Makua
sector and I at various points I felt
more hopeful to be perfectly honest with
you about the possibility of organizing
the service sector I believe that
there's absolutely that I think that the
union movement has no choice it has to
find a way to organize the service
sector and particularly the Macquarie
sector because these are the worst jobs
and it's the mandate of the labor
movement to go where the bad jobs are
figured out the trip but the truth is is
that the challenge could not be more
difficult I've seen over and over again
even successful drives and there are so
few successful drives be undone within a
couple of months when there's complete
staff turnover and the entire base of
support for for the Union disappears and
that's part of what what workers are
organizing against is the fact that that
these jobs are built so that there will
be such high turnover but the fact is
that there there is tremendously high
high turnover and you really end up
having to reorganize these outlets every
year and even the most progressive
unions and I'm thinking particularly the
Canadian Auto Workers Union in Canada
which which has gone after tried very
hard to our
Starbucks and the Teamsters in Canada
has organized McDonald's CAW has
organized in McDonald's in BC and they
keep losing even when they win they lose
the they lose certification within a
year so I'd be interested in hearing
from some of the organizers in the room
about it one interesting idea that I
heard a few years ago when I wrote about
a story for MS magazine on this is the
idea that rather than going after
individual chains you go after a whole
community you target a town and go after
all of basically organize a community
organize all the workers at the
McDonald's the Burger King's the
Starbucks and the gapps everyone all at
once rather than going after the chain
because it doesn't translate through the
chain organizing one Starbucks doesn't
mean you've organized the one down the
streets you have to keep organizing the
shops of eleven people over and over and
over again it's really not
cost-effective so this is what I found
I'm sorry I don't have a more kind of
hopeful answer I wish you could say a
few words about something it's a you
describe very movingly in your book that
this is not just a bunch of do-gooder
groups in North saying oh these are
terrible conditions over there this is a
movement of sweatshop workers in these
countries that are fighting these
contractors for these major corporations
and we're just sort of the transmission
belts you know the groups in the north
are are in an information loop and and
that's really the exciting thing about
it to me is that this information is
being passed on but like you say a few
words about what you saw in Cavite and
and in Indonesia working with the
workers there yeah well one of the most
striking things that I mean I mentioned
that I'm heartened by the fact that the
student movement here has rejected codes
of conduct because or corporate codes of
conduct in particular because when I was
in I spent a lot of time with a group
called the workers Assistance Center
which is the or trying to bring unions
to the largest free trade zone in the
Philippines just outside of Manila and
they when I was there
a couple of years ago they the issue for
them was very very clear they were
trying to bring unions in
to these zones unions were legal in the
Philippines but but these these free
trade zones had been created sort of D
nationalized enclaves essentially
illegal states within within states now
that seems to me to be a very wonderful
opportunity for political organizing all
your all your demanding is is a company
is the country's right to enforce the
laws that it already has these workers
have already fought for the right to
form unions but unions were being
decertified all over the country because
because companies were moving into the
free trade zones and you know inside the
zones they're literally signs that say
do not listen to union organizers or
troublemakers and there's an unspoken no
union no strike rule within the zones so
what the work the organizers who I met
wanted was just plain back up
self-determination the right to form
unions when when there were wildcat
strikes going on every other week
and they needed support for these
specific struggles and and that's that
and and in terms of codes of conduct
they were bewildered by the by the idea
that labor organizers in the States and
in Europe were writing codes without
their input I mean literally bewildered
and furious quite frankly and and and
what what they said to me was you know
they were willing to wait to get even if
it meant not getting as as as good rules
on paper they were willing to take less
the to take sort of smaller concessions
that they had won themselves at the
bargaining table then be handed a piece
of paper that had been negotiated
without their input
Oh what have some of the corporations
you've written about what's their
response been to you it really depends
on the corporation I mean I think that
one thing that has changed and I believe
that the McLibel trial was an enormous
ly educational process for the corporate
world as a whole and it started off with
with this pamphlet these the that London
Greenpeace was distributing blaming
McDonald's for poverty in the third
world for lowering the wages in the
catering industry for litter for
rainforest depletion I mean everything
right they're handing out this leaflet
they got two hundred copies out in the
late 80s and then McDonald's decided to
sue them it's been translated into 26
languages and and millions and millions
of copies of this thing I've been arvit
have been downloaded from the internet
so and in fact I've heard anti nike
campaigners say to me that they wish
that Nike would sue them because if
because part of the issue here key
demand is is transparency is disclosure
and right now we we don't have a legal
basis to make that demand but once a
company is stupid enough to end up in
court with some very tenacious activists
then all of that drops away of course
because the courts enforce a
transparency so what I found find is
that most of the large corporations are
are too smart to try to sue you
that's that's what I found of course
everything in my book is true so what
could they possibly sue me over but
there's plenty of precedent for suing
for suing people for things that are
true just just because you think they're
going to back down and I think that
companies like Nike and Monsanto have
learned the lesson of the colaba and
they don't want that to happen um so
what do what I I'm struggling against is
actually just co-optation it's you know
getting like wonderful calls from Nikes
new president of corporate
responsibility wanting to do a
conference called and you know it's just
sort of like how you kind of get love
bombed by them and this has happened to
me in a few from a few different
corporations and you know the
anti-corporate activism is going to be
the new niche market this is this is the
cover of Benetton's
magazine colors this month is a Mickey
Mickey Mouse ears in blood and they
literally talk about malls as the new
concentration camps I mean this is
colors magazine right so so the
corporate sector has an and Reebok has
it's Human Rights Awards there's all
kinds of sort of niche marketing going
on
I personally am not worried about it at
all because I think that as I you know
one of the main points I'm trying to
make is that particularly young people
are responding to feelings of being over
marketed to our responding to the cool
hunt itself is sort of the root of much
of this backlash so when the cool hint
comes and even font tries to co-opt that
I think it actually radicalizes the
opposition so I hope that sort of
answers the question
mr. nickname
sir I have a notion that consumption in
this country anyway is largely a
mindless business I'll come back to that
with a little illustration from my
outline today and that production is
kind of mindless too I'd refer reference
for that wooden writers book on the
global economy
as a kind of mindless process nobody's
responsible for what's going on instant
trading in billions of dollars by people
who really are not aware or concern or
can they key with the consequences I
bought a shirt for seven bucks last
weekend and put it on this morning I had
a brand on it so I decided take the
scissors to the Brad took it off and the
navigating the hold of the shirt but I
bought it because it was seven dollars
and what I'm really interested in since
so much of this is mindless the
consumption like mine and the production
itself so you you you put pins in the in
the overinflated rooms and they're gone
let's say but the mindless production
and the minus consumption goes on so
what is your prescription really to deal
with this giant amorphous thing called
globalism well first of all I don't
think that I'm responding to globalism
and I think that if anything I'm
responding to corporatism but because I
think that part of part of what we're up
against is a total conflation of
globalization with corporatization and
what we need to do is try to reimagine a
kind of globalization that is different
from the one that we have right now
because I think that there are a lot of
people who who are who are in fact for
globalization and taken with the promise
of globalization that has not been
fulfilled
in terms of the rest of your question
it's a very difficult one I think that
these brands are playing a very powerful
powerful surrogate role in all of our
lives the issue is not you know being a
mindless consumer the issue is allowing
allowing this branding process to be
effective because we are so hungry for
meaning that we look to it we're even
willing to take it from our sneakers and
lattes and so I think that the way to
deal with it is not to sort of you know
try to deal with it directly like you
know you're stupid for thinking you're
going to get spiritual enlightenment
from your sneakers what's wrong with you
but actually trying to look at at at the
at the at the holes in our culture in
the way in which we're failing in the
public sphere and in a sense I think
that then branding which I think has a
role in any market economy in any
economy it falls into a much more
appropriate place the issue is that it
is so inflated that it's replaced all of
these all of all of these other sectors
and and so it has to somehow be brought
into check the reason why I am heartened
by what we what we're seeing with
student organizing is that I actually
think that one of the ways to replace
this obsession with branding is to
become politically engaged as citizens
to see oneself as a citizen as well as a
shopper so in a way you kill two birds
with one stone you you people become
politically engaged as citizens and then
they probably care a little bit less
about the logos they're wearing at the
same time because part of what these
logos are selling us and in the case of
Benetton and Starbucks is in fact a
pseudo political movement I mean that's
what Nike is doing when it sells these
feminists feminists ads and and there's
essentially packaging our most cherished
values and ideas as brand extensions
yes I'm going to talk a little bit more
about the potential social base for
larger mobilization against this kind of
new economy so building on Seattle but
you you seem to be optimistic about you
know the potential for that and and I
don't think it's an accident that you
come back to the student population and
I think that there's a reason for that
and that students are still living
within communities and are taking part
sharing in some kind of a common
experience for which they can be
mobilized and mobilize each other to
take on this cause and what worries me
and I guess the reason why I'm less
optimistic is that I think that one of
the outcomes of the new economy is to
really fragment people they're not
members of unions they're not staying
with job they're part-time workers
without you know some ongoing
identification with a consistent group
of other workers and there's so many
ways that that you've outlined many of
them that people are isolated as
consumers workers and so forth it I when
you think about the history of
mobilization and what it takes getting
people to really act together um I don't
know
we have the ingredients for that yeah
well I think it comes back to the
earlier question about organizing the
mick work sector as well the service
sector workers because of course this is
about the fact that in many ways that
schools are only it's the only vestige
of sort of full-time civic life and and
that unions are not stepping into that
role so I think that that's all it's all
the more reason why we need to sort of
solve this problem of how to organize
this massive sector in the economy
because that is one way to continue to
continue into you know post university
into into our so-called real lives the
other thing is that I think unions need
to American unions I've been so
impressed by the success of unions
summer I have to say because even though
I know it's been a really controversial
project I've interviewed dozens and
dozens of students involved in
anti-corporate activism of various kinds
and I've asked them over and over again
you know how did this start how did you
get involved and so many of them said
unions summer I interned at unite one
summer and you know next thing I knew I
was running the guest campaign at Yale
or this or that and I but really I've
heard it over and over again so I mean
it this is a really forward-looking
project of you know building activists
that I think are going to continue on
after University as well I do I do
understand I understand why it seems
like I'm being overly optimistic and
that is why I'm concentrating on the
campuses because I think that that
tremendous change can come from there
but I do think that unions the American
unions have have changed dramatically
not enough moving away from
protectionism to to taking a more global
outlook which is allowing for this which
is allowing for these bridges to to to
be created between the student movement
between the environmental movement all
of that and I think in many ways this
what's really great
these anti corporate campaigns I quote a
British campaigner named John Jordan who
was involved in the anti Seattle
protests and he says you know what's
great about these multinationals is
they've helped us to see the this system
as interrelated that there's there's a
connection if you look at a brand like
shell environmental concerns labor
concerns human rights concerns you know
through this one lens and that's why I
think they are helpful because they do
build between social movements and and
and so I would look to their for hope as
well oh yeah just thinking through your
talk I said I kind of see this trend
which it started out companies created a
product and the product started to sell
then it didn't sell as much than they
needed to create a need
rizzoli began marketing and that worked
for a while then they needed to create
an image then they created branding I'm
wondering in your opinion what do you
think is next see I'm not sure if there
is an X this is the thing I mean I know
there's always supposed to be a next but
it's the next big thing I mean this is
what I've been coming to with you know
okay brands have always been able to
sort of co-opt their opposition and and
and just reinvent themselves into
something new as you say but I I
sometimes really get the feeling that
particularly with this co-opting of anti
corporatism that they're actually
following their target market off a
cliff that there is nowhere to go once
you once once and because we've seen
marketing absorb every type of content
critique possible whether it's feminism
or subliminal advertising or or racism
everything advertising can can absorb
any critique that is leveled at the
mechanics of advertising but I'm not
sure it can absorb a critique against
the fact of advertising I don't really
see how you do that I could be missing
some trick
I want to make that comical because
there is a things like okay we're
planning this next okay it know it and
it includes involves with all the
information you're going to have on
people on the internet so when you want
to buy your sneakers I don't have to
tell you it's a Nike I it's your
personal thing and I can it with enough
information I can sort of app exactly
what you want you want it with a the
union label on it give it to you you
want over the radical slogan on it I
give it you personally you see a little
bit of this in the amazon.com you go on
decide and they know what the previous
books you bought are yeah I offer you
some other things so and my sense of
talking with advertisers is what they
think is the ultimate thing is where
they will have enough information on
every person nothing this is that's like
that but we're rather than give you any
mass piece of information yeah they just
the product is exactly what you want and
then that would be the next to this yeah
I would make it very hard because it
with the label wouldn't matter it's your
personal you know thing they don't your
size and know what you like and they
here's the peers what we have exactly
suited for you visual usual folks
responsible ones on the same umbrella
you want socially responsible made some
fun will give you that we have other
ones over here at our self social news
box
so an example that would be at the like
the CK NY perfume that's non branded
there is no image it's a non image image
and that's what they target um well I
have a question but I also want to just
comment on this that one group of
individuals who work through that I
think the nail foundation were trying to
get at how you encourage the public to
think more critically about advertising
as an entity and one way that they came
upon thinking about this is to look at
the ways advertising harms health and
they picked tobacco alcohol and fashion
industry advertising and they looked at
how it harms women's health and
particularly young women and they
produce this little video redefining
liberation which I've used a bit with
mostly high school and college age women
and and young men as well and I think it
has been an effective tool just sparking
what is usually a given for most people
in this carries that advertising is
great that's how you find out about
things there's a very little reflection
upon how it can hurt you or be bad for
you and this creates a wedge into that
sort of given an assumption I think it's
done some good things this kind of
thinking and you know encouraging the
viewer to be a critical thinker and to
realize that you get manipulated in all
kinds of ways now they're always one
step ahead and I know Brown & Williamson
has this fabulous duty if you caught
their number and they sing about the
tobacco plant how it's bad for you and
if you're under certain age it's so
clever it sucks you in um yeah very very
effectively and they also produce things
it looks so wonderful that you don't
even know what's inside so doctors are
now putting out in their offices these
great things on simple living for women
that all have that tobacco advertising
inside
don't even know it because they haven't
looked beyond the table contents in the
cover I'm actually encouraged since WTO
and Seattle because I found so many
college-age students who weren't in it
because they were going to succeed in
fact most of them were quite
sophisticated enough to realize that we
probably won't succeed in most of these
efforts but there's such a thing as
damage control you know things would be
worse were it not for you to be in the
fight so to speak and I think they were
a lot of students who were in it because
it was the right thing to do and they
weren't fixated on well it's not worth
trying because I won't succeed which is
what I used to hear all the time and I
had that occur to me and there was a
sense of joy about it too I mean I
thought about what happened to cam desus
was it yesterday when he gave his exit
speech at the IMF somebody went up got
in through security and put the food pie
in his face right before he was to give
his talk and that kind of thing will
make the news where is a reason critique
won't and then somebody who doesn't even
know what the IMF is we might even find
out a little bit more about it that to
me was the you know these things more v
GATT goes into WTO and you know there
was the trilateral commission and they
were shadow governments and everything
is the same sort of misuse of power by a
few Elise who want to maintain their
control and so they latch on to new ways
of sort of distracting us but that it
the thing that excited me about WTO is I
felt like there was a group of people
ready for a long haul now I don't know
whether that will happen but that felt
committed and creative and worried about
quick interested in creating community
and to see the sea turtle advocates with
the steelworkers with the
representatives from faith-based
communities in the the kind of
representation which didn't come across
in the median I actually felt like they
had to go a long way to hide that fact
because it was so visible um it does
lend itself to believing in conspiracies
among media folks but it's another issue
oh sorry here um just a couple of brand
anecdotes in that economy um I went in
because if there's some sort I feel like
there's no place else be you know if it
wasn't wanted by something close or
something because I don't make you
myself to go buy a pair pants so well
alright so there's a cab hardware which
is sort of like nice I think of as a
place where I can go get a beer
I was in here the other day and I was
looking at the exact same pair of pants
and one was made in the Dominican
Republic one was made in Honduras and
the exact same time and they were made
in three different countries indoors
the vinegar public I forget me Taiwan
which raised for me and one interesting
side question is T are they paying
everybody
each of these friends the same probably
not of the working conditions the same
benefits the same the cost of production
the same that was an interesting world
experience the second thing like my
nephew was given to my kind of homes
well not hard but I was a little bit
disappointed he was given one of these
black I did like the fact it was a black
hooded sweatshirt but it was a Nike
black hooded sweatshirt for Christmas
and what I was a little surprised and I
say thing and then the next day he
showed up and he had taken a black magic
marker not because anybody said anything
to him and he blackened out the Nike
symbol and I was like where wow where to
get that and kind of show it to me kind
of like quietly like with Iams if he was
kind of proud he wanted to show share it
with me
and I was kind of touched by that and
encouraged that there was like this
undercurrent from high school kids in
New Jersey you know I don't spend a lot
of time with that so you know my brother
and his kids but there's this like
current of rejection of
kind of thing and then his Christmas
present to me was when corporations rule
the world this book by David Gore quite
more important and I heard of it and I
hadn't know how did he know about this
book it was like real it was really kind
of a trip Mike might my comment is about
this taking an example of something like
Starbucks Starbucks is something that
people can relate to not just as a
corporate brand or all the stuff about
the coffee but in terms of what happens
in your kinam you may have spoken about
this what happens not in where the
coffee has grown
I mean starbucks made a deal with with
coughing organic suppose you know
defined as organic coffee growers in
East Timor
it was written about in the Wall Street
Journal I don't think it's gonna say
Starbucks but people in people care see
what happens when there's a small
locally owned neighborhood coffee shop
and they see the Starbucks open up next
door and that ends up being an enormous
impact negative impact for people that
arouses a different kind of opposition
to Starbucks so there's a opportunity
for coalition building across different
reasons for challenging the corporations
behind the corporate brands there's a
great example and there's a sort of how
these brands do bring people together
I've see I've seen Starbucks people
concerned about losing a community
artist-run
cafe joining with students who were
trying to bring a union to their to
their Starbucks coffee shop joining with
campaigners who were trying to highlight
issues around around where the coffee
was being picked and by whom in
Guatemala so so sort of it's the global
economy in miniature and it's it's not
going to get you very far if if that's
where it ends and it ends up being like
a competing brand versus brand but as a
popular education tool you couldn't ask
for anything better
as long as as long as you know how to
take it to the next
step I'm banging trade unionist I'm
encouraged to nothing there's the least
five or six of us that are we see mom
was buoyant I worked for a long time
with Canadian trade unions and others on
the mi I am anti ma on and then I spent
about a year working with international
trade genius labor people trying to get
some consistent position across many
labor movements across many cultures in
many countries and I was encouraged
because in fact I think we came very
close to it and for me I saw more
unanimity in terms of definition of
problem and proposed solutions to
globalization that I've seen in over a
decade decade or 15 years in labor so
that encourages me the other thing that
encouraged me in Seattle was the young
people and I want to go back to this
point that you made earlier on the the
people at a we're working with and I was
meeting and talking to it wasn't it was
almost a visceral in the sense it was it
was is it the corporate problem from
their standpoint many corporations have
just got a bit too much over the top as
it were and and that's what really
fascinates me when you talk about
branding back that really interests me
because the trade union has been being
involved in boycotts consumer boycotts
we ran as a consumer boycott of Sony
products in Canada prior to Christmas
you can imagine what kind of a dented
head on sale
yeah you know there was the movement the
labor was trying to run a bike up but I
what I find interesting and what I mean
what it would appreciate you calling it
going is this distinction between
consumer boycotts and this visceral sort
of branding back where you've got people
that are 16 17 18 20 that are just
saying hey I've had it up to here fast
enough already
that is enough your your stuff right
yeah can you talk a bit about that that
sense of branding back and that sort of
visceral reaction that that it seems is
growing it's I mean it's absolutely true
and the Economist magazine right after
after Seattle and it's it's a ongoing
campaign to to do attack the the
protesters talked about what hypocrites
these students were here they were
sucking back their designer lattes and
wearing you know probably made in China
running shoes complaining about trade
and this was of course supposed to make
the campaigners look very stupid that
they had allowed these inconsistencies
to take place and I think that that
speaks to the fact that as you say this
is not consumer this is really although
there is often a consumer element
I actually think that the greatest
danger is that it will just degenerate
into lifestyle politics as much as the
environmental movement and the 80s did
and it'll just become about you know is
your laundry detergent in green or not
you know is you are your shoes no sweat
I mean this it is possible I joked about
it but it is possible for this to
generate into into niche marketing and I
think the reason why it isn't is because
it comes from a more visceral place than
that and I think the best example of
that is is is them I sort of first
started noticing this anti-corporate
activism through the rise of culture
jamming ad busting ad parroting which is
happening more and more because of
access to new tech to to to information
technologies which allows you to
download an ad off the internet have the
original and you know mess with it on
your on your desktop and have it look
really slick and have it look exactly
like that gap campaign and you know
repost it to your friends and
you know put it up if you like where I
first started seeing that was on
university campuses where there were ads
ads had started appearing in washrooms
above urinals and in bathroom stalls
which was the stupidest thing if you
think about it
if you think about the psychology that's
why I say sometimes it feels like brands
follow their target market off of a
cliff because here you are branding
putting an ad in a washroom in a
university campus which is a space for
so long has been a space for
self-expression let's just say right I
mean this is where students take out
their magic markers and say what they
actually think their eyeliners and stuff
and and so for the first time you
started it just crossed a line and all
of these students whose own parents his
own educators had been saying you know
what they're so branded what does it
matter if we just put in another ad I
mean that's what they say to themselves
when when they sign the deal that
there's going to be you know ads and
washrooms they say not this is a good
idea but who really cares because these
kids are bombarded from day one it's not
another ad is not going to is not going
to matter but what was interesting is
that it did matter there was just this
sort of visceral kind of uprising and in
fact the ads were under such attack on
many university campuses that they
yanked them because it was not
cost-effective at all and yet in terms
of branding back as I said I believe
that that that Nike the reason the
reason why the Nike campaign has been so
tenacious and I think that we cannot
underestimate the power of this Nike
Nike has been under the microscope for
over five years five years ten years but
five years big time in the public eye
grassroots campaigning before that now
since when can a company just you know
have five people say on staff full time
dealing with an issue put out PR spin
after PR spin in fact change their
practices in several ways and have it
not matter you know we're talking about
a culture where there was you know the
Exxon Valdez spill
and a couple weeks later was like
alright what's next right but the Nike
campaign has legs and it has legs
because there's a certain there's a part
of of of us and I think particularly for
young people who just who aren't buying
it and who the more corporations respond
with spin the more distrust there is
because it comes from this feeling of
being of being over marketed to so I
actually believe that there's a there's
a part of the culture that does not want
the Nike campaign to go away it actually
wants it to just hang around and so that
so that they can watch the company
squirm squirm and there's no precedent
for dealing with this type of activists
and because it isn't just about boycotts
and it isn't just about consumer
activism it's about rage that's what
Microsoft is about as well it's about
you know I mean it started in the
hackers hacker community where Microsoft
was sort of branded as the evil empire
and it spread to the broader culture
with you know Bill Gates wealth pages
and so just a sort of visceral reaction
that there's just something wrong here
this person is too rich you know it's
just you know it's not trickling down at
the you know there has to be a place
where it stops and and it's really the
companies are having a lot of trouble
controlling this because it is emotional
it is not it's not just something that
you can solve right away just a softball
question I happen to notice okay that
this is the Canadian version of your
book this is the US version of your book
now I do you like better what's going on
with the branding here well my canadian
heritage likes this one my us obviously
prefers this one what's what's going on
with your publisher here there's two
different publishers for you to market
on the same page they do have bill gates
eating a pie yes it's the exact same
inside um well this Black Edition is the
same in Canada and the UK and you
Americans you can tell me if it's true
they said that the Americans you know
they needed pow it's America you know we
can't just have a stark black cover so I
said okay and so we did we did this
parody of a babyGap bed I like them both
it's sort of like writing two books for
the price of one so he's happy about
that I just just dumb your expression a
while ago about love bombs was was an
interesting to her that before it's a
nice concept I I think this this is sort
of connected to yeah apartment
Valentine's Day love bombs at Harvard
University but I remember reading I
think relatively recently at global
exchange which is a I think widely
thought it was a fairly progressive
group that's been involved in putting
pressure on Nike and so forth was
getting a lot of heat from people on the
left and perhaps appropriately for kind
of I don't know going on one of the
trips with Nike people and and being
there when Nike raised the wage and and
therefore and then they went back and
put out these this publicity that said
well Nikes been a good boy and and then
the left landed on them yeah and and so
it's a question of like you know what's
incredible place to stand when you've
got love bombs going at you when they
start doing the right thing you know
what's the you know where the plateaus
or whatever I mean because this is
obviously seems to be a long-term
campaign of some resistance and cultural
change and and there will be love bombs
there will be they will do the right
thing on occasion but that and they need
to be recognized for that but on the
other hand it's not enough yeah so then
how do
you handle that sort of slippery slope
so to speak
well I think that groups get into that
kind of trouble when they when they
start negotiating on behalf of workers
who they shouldn't be negotiating on
behalf of in the first place and I mean
that wasn't up to global exchange to
decide when Nike had done had done
enough because as Jeff pointed out these
these campaigns start with workers in
Indonesia and the Philippines and China
organizing wildcat strikes and making
demands losing their jobs and so on
they'll say when Nikes okay
Nike will be okay when they're at the
bargaining table and I think that a lot
of groups and I respect the work of
global exchange I think they've done
some amazing stuff but I think that that
that that the response of the
corporations has just in the past two
years has actually surprised a lot of
NGOs because they weren't ready for it
because it has been so dramatic you know
that going from denial that there was a
problem to you know name calling a bunch
of fringe groups you know a really
direct location of global exchange by
Nike specifically - okay let's sit down
together and write the rules oh you
think you know you this is your study
you think that there should be arrays
okay well we'll raise workers wages six
percent which is what happened and I
think that that was such a dramatic
shift that that it kind of blindsided
some of these groups and they I believe
that they lost perspective or what were
who they were fighting for what they
were fighting for with weight were what
they were fighting for was
self-determination for workers who were
beginning to organize themselves and
needed back up not to write not to
decide themselves in San Francisco when
Nike had done enough
well a comment I sort of had I haven't
read your book I don't have to talk
about this but I think that a real
problem you know you talk about groups
that speak for workers what happened in
the case of child labor is a real
example of what happened when people
here decided to speak for children there
in the case of Bangladesh which is where
I'm from there was a big education about
child labor and the Harkins bill came
into play and what happened in
Bangladesh was that a lot of children
were pushed out of the garment industry
and they started working in UNICEF said
they started working in high rates of
child Constitution they started doing
welding and despite repeated attempts by
a lot of labor activists in Bangladesh
to tell you know activist groups here
that the children should still be
continued to a lot to work but with
regulations there was just this sort of
like we've decided the child labor is
not good therefore we're not going to
let it to exist in any case and there
was a meeting between the Bangladesh
government of Manufacturers Association
and USAID where they were trying to have
a deal where they would pay workers to
lease for half the day go and go to
school but USAID said we cannot have any
involvement whatsoever with anything to
do with child labor because of what the
US public is demanding and I think
that's like an example of why we really
have to be careful about when you know
with the groups here speak for groups
there and when it really is a valid
voice and I think that I think we'll
probably have to end there but it is it
is really about changing the culture
because I think that what part of part
of the problem is that we are such a
consumer-based culture that we actually
want quick service for our grievances
right it's like we have found a problem
and we would like a solution tomorrow
and and that's I think how how these no
sweat and labels start start seeming
like viable solutions and and bills with
no consultations start seeming like
their survival solutions and so I think
that what you said about being heartened
by the fact that you're meeting young
people who are saying we're in it for
the long haul
you know we don't actually expect to get
results tomorrow I think is is
is really heartening because that's
that's the most important shift is to
get out of this sort of consumer mindset
when it comes to political activism
thank you all for coming